rescue operations at the site of one of
India's worst trained disasters in
decades has now ended these are live
picture from odisha state where bodies
are being identified at a makeshift Mall
more than 300 people died and up to a
thousand were injured in a crash
involving three trains unofficial
inquiries underway but many are blaming
signaling failure Harry Fawcett reports
the scale of this crash almost defies
comprehension a fast-moving passenger
train rammed into a freight train
minutes later another passenger train
plowed into the wreckage India's prime
minister visiting the scene of his
nation's worst such disaster in decades
hundreds of people were killed hundreds
more injured emergency crews searching
for anyone alive or dead still trapped
inside the mangled carriages survivors
described moments of sheer Terror
Carriage started shaking we got scared
when we realized what was going on we
tried to get out we broke the windows
and managed to get out
India's government has been spending
heavily on new stations high-speed
trains and other upgrades but its
critics accuse it of failing to
prioritize safety on an aging Network
that carries 13 million people a day
nearby hospitals have been overwhelmed
families waiting desperately for updates
others have lined up in clinics to
donate blood prime minister muddy went
from the track side to hospital bedsides
he spoke of his own anguish and pain
promising the best treatment for the
injured and support for the grieving
this incident is very serious for the
government orders for carrying out a
thorough investigation have been given
and whoever is found guilty will get the
strictest punishment
that person will not be spared
by Nightfall The Rescue and Recovery
work had been declared over a railway
official said the disaster had been
caused by a signaled failure that
diverted the passenger train onto the
wrong track
as the nation Mourns it's also
questioning Anew the safety of the
world's fourth largest rail network
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera well um Sharif
is at the site of the train crash in
balasore uh called Swim sir just bring
us up to date with what's been happening
there
foreign
it's a half past 10 local time in
India's eastern state of vedicia and
behind me what you see is the site of
the massive accident we saw on Friday
evening involving three trains and now
what remains is what you see behind men
have their tasks cut out they've been
working in this heat in the humidity
trying to fix the rails trying to fix
these coaches I would rather move these
mangled coaches out of the way they're
trying to fix those wires out there we
have people from the State national
disaster management Force we have the
fire police we have the police we have
the Army Personnel all of them are out
here and in fact as we see these
carriages look like little boxes just
strewn around into the Farmland around
the place it's going to take hours
before they're going to be able to fix
this and a lot of the Rails have just
blown out so there are no rails so it'll
be long before this this rail route is
going to be functional because many
trains have been canceled and that
brings out to the other part of the
thing the families who are trying to get
here it's hard for him for hard for them
to get here because many trains are
canceled a local reporter told us even
buses are canceled many of them won't
reach to the hospitals around this place
some of them have moved to another city
called Qatar the most seriously injured
are there we know the death toll has
gone up to above 300. so a lot of things
happening on the ground here of course
in hospitals in mortuaries people are
trying to look for loved ones those who
can't find their family members are just
hoping there's a ray of hope that maybe
we will find them and we'll find them
alive there's also they're also anxious
they hope they hope and pray for the
best but as of now the officials say
that this is what they are going to be
doing throughout the day despite the
heat despite the humidity dozens of
people onto the left side I can see
tents put up where all these staff when
they're finishing a bit of work are
taking some rest and cooling off there
all right um Sharif they're live for us
at the train crash site in balasore call
soon thank you